do you think he was eating meat when he
had his multiple dinners with Jeffrey
Epstein now one of the issues that's
dogged you is is that of your
relationship with Jeffrey Epstein do you
regret the relationship that you
maintained with him against Melinda's
advice and wishes I've said that I'm I
mean this is you're going way back in
time but yeah new audience I will say
for the you know over a hundredth time
yeah I shouldn't have had uh dinners
with him
um Epstein had a way of sexually
compromising people is that what Melinda
was warning you about
no
I mean it's
no I I had dinner with them uh and
that's all
and that you regret the relationship the
acquaintance that I had dinner with them
and and the relationship between the
foundation and Epstein which there never
was any relationship of any kind
okay you might note that he contradicts
himself well first off he does this
weird smiley thing again as it seems
like he's lying but at one point he says
dinner then he said dinners also it's
very unclear if there was a direct
relationship between Epstein and the
Gates Foundation you know Epstein was
funding all sorts of things that Gates
has his hands in whether it's the
Harvard endowment like all sorts of
crazy things
um but you know if you didn't do
anything with Epstein why do you regret
having dinner with the guy that's a
little kind of curious
[Music]
foreign